hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds and in this video I wanted to
answer the common question that I get
all the time should you quit your job to
the property full-time you should not
quit your job to do property full-time
if you are unsure if you're thinking
should I then don't do it and the reason
I say that is because it's very easy to
earn a full time living in property part
on what I mean by that if you work in
site Monday to Friday then what you
could do is on your lunch breaks Monday
to Friday is you could book property
viewings for the Saturday and then those
Saturday instead of sitting at home on
the couch watching daytime TV doing a
bit of shopping instead of doing that
you could go out and view all the
properties that you booked you could
package them up and then on the Sunday
you could write a sales email that you
could then send out it on your lips
breaks again or in the evenings to
investors on Facebook and you could
package if you just sort and sold one
deal a month which is terrible it would
replace the average income if you're
thinking I don't know should I quit to
do property full-time no do it part-time
and earn a full time living and then you
can quit and then as Jim Rohn says
instead of working part-time on your
fortune and full-time on your job you
can then work full-time on your fortune
which is when things get really excited
if however you're already doing that or
if you're like making money you're doing
promising a little bit on the side and
you just your job is just such a
distraction and you're thinking ah you
know this is just absolutely hindering
me then yeah quit your job it also
depends on things like can you afford to
quit your job if there's two of you you
and you and your partner and your
partners working in your work in but
you're saving two grand a month each
month then you're pretty comfortable
when you've got some money in the bank
maybe yeah quit your job but if you're
struggling to make ends meet and you
need your job then just do property
part-time there's different stages
there's full-time in property then
there's financially free then there's
ultimately financially free and then
there's mission which is where you just
get to a point where you just make loads
of money and growing a big legacy and
you're doing it from a position of
abundance and mission it's not for the
money at all and what I would say is
don't quit your job until your
least at the first level where you think
I could do this full-time or I'm making
a bit of passive income that's my
thoughts that's my thoughts and if
you're even asking me the question to
try and get me to say quit your job you
want me to endorse your thought it means
you're not running nobody before you
even begin thinking about this stuff
that you need to get trained come down
to the property investors crash course
we have people becoming financially free
and quitting their jobs all the time but
they always invest in themselves first
so get try and get educated if you want
to start this journey description below
get yourself booked on
[Music]